how's everyone doing
[Applause]
uh
yeah I can't believe we're in here and
we're back at Comic-Con I just want to
say thank you all for coming out today
um
yeah let's just jump into this uh ladies
and gentlemen I would like to introduce
our panelists up first we have Louis
letterier
we now have Justin Simeon
and someone named Gareth Edwards
I guess you're next to me
right it's written Please be aware that
many members of our audience may be
under 18 years of age it's written right
here I am so seriously I'm about to say
okay uh I just want to say that uh you
guys know not to film the stuff we're
going to put on the screens uh we're
going to be premiering some never before
seen footage and before we get into what
we're about to do I really want to give
a huge thank you to Eddie for letting me
do this panel
uh and a huge thank you to Saad and
everyone at Disney for providing the
exclusive footage that we're going to be
running during this panel and I think
you guys know or if you don't know at
the end of the panel we're gonna have
these exclusive posters from Haunted
Mansion and the Creator again thank you
Disney for uh and they're really really
good posters so before we get started
um I think some of you like let's have a
little refresher of some of the work
that these gentlemen have directed
give a huge thank you to my friend Jeff
for cutting that Sizzle uh thank you
Jeff that was great
well done Jeff
thanks Jeff
[Laughter]
wherever you are you're Jeff right no no
I am definitely not Jeff Jefferson this
audience oh Jeff
give it up for Jeff y'all stand up Jeff
stand up
right there yes there Jeff there it is
very punk rock panel I'm I just want to
say that otherwise there's no way Disney
and everyone would approve having Fast
and Furious and Star Wars and everything
else in the same clip you know uh so
let's jump in
um gentlemen you guys have done some
exceptional work if someone has never
seen anything you've directed before
what is the first thing you'd like them
watching and why
for all of you guys
I mean for me dear white people because
first of all uh clearly the country
needs an education in all of the themes
that that film uh deals with but uh
because of my first film and it was the
it was the one where like I did you know
the most of my like cinematic quoting
and I think like you can kind of trace a
lot of my inspiration and references uh
in that film so I'm gonna say start with
the start with the start with my first
one
hmm
yeah come on Jeff
Jeff
give it up
so sorry
um I think I'm the last person that's
any good at judging what my best thing
is and so but I do remember one occasion
I was in LA I was walking across the
street and some guy looked at me and
it's one of those rare occasions where
you think oh I think he recognized
me and he kept staring at me as he kept
going past and I kept walking and he got
to the side and I could hear someone
going hey hey and I was like I'm not
gonna look I'm not going to look and he
went hey and I I thought okay I'll look
now and I turned around and he said I
love moon it's my favorite film and he
thought I was Duncan Jones
and and so I have to say my best movie
is Moon by Duncan Jones
good it's a really good one
you know what happened after that I I
sort of know Duncan and I texted him and
I said
um some guy just shouted across the
street at me saying he loved Moon and he
said well it is your best film
uh no I mean that's that's the best
answer exactly no it's like I mean you
know I think I've done I've done so many
movies it's very hard to pick every time
I'm like you know you you love the
movies I don't know about you guys I
cannot watch my movies after I've done
them right it's like it's impossible
I've never seen I turned them off
they're on people don't believe that
they think you're being like humble
right but I've never watched a film I've
done I've never thought of it when it's
finished never never and it's really
hard for us to have people come to you
and say I love this you know but you
know it's good when it's somebody else's
movie but like you know I love this
because you don't know how to respond
you're like thank you I don't know where
you know you got so many mixed mixed
feelings we'll talk about this today but
yeah uh yeah it's a it's a it's very
troubling to be a director and you'll
realize this in the next 90 minutes
uh what do you think fans would be
surprised to learn about making a movie
and directing in Hollywood
just one thing
no well stop it's actually for me right
so yeah I'll stop with me it's very
collaborative I really
directing in general we're not painters
we're not sculptors we're directors you
surround yourself with a cast a crew
writers and frankly a studio
that everybody wants to make the best
movie you all want to make one thing and
and and it's like a marriage it's
dialogue it's about communication you
work together and then ultimately and
that's what's nice in Hollywood is I've
done a lot of stuff
outside of Hollywood in Europe I mean
Hollywood at the end of the day the
audience would tell will tell you if
they like it or they don't because
you'll do screen testing you'll do you
know trailers and you you sort of like
have this relationship together with an
audience so I really really enjoy this
process the collaboration is really nice
and when it works it works when it
doesn't work when it when it breaks down
when the studio and it will happen to
each and every one of us we will be
hired
for because we pitched something and six
months into the process they'll ask you
to do the exact opposite for which for
what you will that you were asked you
were hired you said you should have
hired the other person no they hired you
and we'll give you the opposite that
actually is communication breakdown and
that's the worst moment in a director's
career
yeah I think for me it's like how
unplanned it is because you are
obviously a director there's a lot of
um planning that has to go into it but
really for me where the metal meets the
road where the rubber reads the road I'm
sorry y'all I I haven't slept in a while
um is really like when things go to
crap let me read this sign under 18.
when things go to crap is really when
you figure out what kind of a director
you are because as you said like even
with the best laid plans even when you
execute those plans you take that thing
to a test greeting and people are like
we really don't care we do not we we see
all of it we don't care it goes right
over our heads or when you put a movie
out in the world and audiences decide
what it is because that's actually what
that's when a movie actually comes to
life is when your intentions as a
filmmaker and uh the experience of the
audience kind of meet each other so
there's a lot of like kind of you you
have to plan uh as much as you can but
kind of be open to spontaneity one of my
favorite uh books is this 2001 A Space
Odyssey Memoir about the relationship
with uh yeah give it up for Stanley
Kubrick uh at Arthur C Clarke and you
realize things like oh the reason the
Obelisk is is is the is the shape that
it is it's because Stanley Cupid wanted
it to be a big glass pyramid and that
looked like crap when he built it and so
they just painted like a cigarette box
and that's why and you when you
experience it you're like oh my God what
is the meaning of this object and why is
it that shape and oh the way it's you
know and some of it's really intentional
and some of it's just like yo we have a
cigarette box
Paint It Black because the pyramid looks
terrible you know
um yeah I mean I think when you start
before you get to do this I always
thought like growing up wanting to be a
director if someone had said here's a
pie chart I want you to fill it in with
what your job will be yeah I would have
drawn like 90
um imagining shots maybe talking to
actors but mainly like just conceiving
the movie and the reality is that's like
five percent of it and 95 is like
imagine a queue of like 200 strangers
and you have to convince all 200 that
that idea that shot that concept is the
right choice and each one will like
fight you for it and you have to work
your way through all of these people
through the process of making a movie
and it's like just Relentless in terms
of Defending Your Ideas and you know
things like that so it's it's it's five
percent creative and like 95 percent
political yeah that's really real and
and what people see on the other side is
the five percent that you intended and
whether or not that was successful but
it's like listen I'm lucky to get 3.7
of that five percent through to the
final if you you know play all of those
battles right so that's I couldn't agree
with that more
we all know about the projects you have
made but uh for all of you do you have
any projects that were really close to
going and that ultimately fell apart yes
would you like to share nope
yeah come on I don't know what y'all I'm
gonna share you're sure
Disney is uh there is is paying for me
to be here right now so I don't think I
should talk about anything
else I have nothing to promote I'm from
just like here so yeah
Gareth
um yeah totally yeah the thing you can't
talk about it that's the problem
um I I find that I tend to I don't know
about you but when you go to a meeting
about film you know within the first
there's basically two types of meetings
there's a meeting where they're
genuinely interested they really want to
do this and it's like uh you know the
room is like very welcoming and stuff
and then there's a meeting where they're
like oh God we have to listen to this
because it's rude not to and you don't
know what you're going to get until you
get into the room and within the first
20 seconds of talking you realize that
this is just a pretense there's no way
they're gonna make this
and at that point I wish I could just
stop you know and just put everything
away and go you know what it's all cool
I feel like within I've never really got
a film like down the road properly it's
usually like straight away you know it's
it's not going to happen yeah for me
it's usually like uh
you know you have a a bunch of really
great initial meetings uh and the people
that you're meeting with are like
genuinely excited and then their bosses
uh come into the picture and they're not
so sure or they were just in the
shareholder meeting or whatever goes on
you know above our pay grades and
somewhere in the middle it changes like
when you were talking about how like
okay the very thing we hired you to do
let's not do that that's the opposite
that's that's uh yeah that's pretty
common I got it
um I'll tell you a couple of things that
where I was very close to I don't care
[Laughter]
a small one that I really loved it was
called it's called Yellowstone Falls
it's it's after the fall of your of
civilization
um every human is a zombie and it's when
the zombies have nothing else to eat but
animals and they turn on the animals and
it's the story of a wolf pack the the
alpha wolf gets killed and it's the
story of it would have been the most
complicated movie to direct because it
was a real wolf it was like a wolf
mother and a three pups Crossing
Yellowstone chased by a horde of zombies
the lead being was Danny McBride so wow
Yellowstone Falls the move it was a
50-page script no dialogue Grunts and
Danny McBride perfect I want to see this
immediately
immediately I'm like I was so close I
saw your body the whole thing and then
you know yeah like you said like
somebody you know I was in a pitch
meeting and then everybody said nah
are you joking I'm not joking I've
already did this it's a hundred percent
it's called Yellowstone Falls it's my uh
Magnus helper magnificent I will never
get to do it I did though produce a
movie that's coming out called Strays
with uh R-rated dogs that's coming out
with the Lord and Miller and Eric feig
who is one of the producer was the guy
who said no because he was the head of
Lionsgate and now and now he's like came
to me to produce the thing I was like
remember when it's a bad dog it's like
anyway uh so anyway we bear the the
hatchet and the second one that I really
loved and worked so hard I did I worked
for and I'm lucky I'm like I work for
eight months with James Cameron on a
Fantastic Voyage you know the the the
Isaac azimov thing and we're we were
inventing cameras we're doing all that
stuff and everything at the whole plan
solerno uh written the script it was
amazing it's amazing it was like What
Dreams what Inception is to Dreamscape
this was going to be to uh you know the
original movie and then uh we pitched it
and it was killed in the room it was
like it was literally I was like eight
months we had like everything and this
is how we're going to revive show scan
you know stuff that was like absolutely
incredible new cameras new everything
and then they were like no we will keep
making Avatar movies uh with you James
and you cannot direct and ever produce
anything complicated was was James
Cameron with you when you pitched it was
he in the room no that's the problem
it's like it's a good story I could not
reach him I was like I'm pitching today
I'm pitching are you here are you here
could not reach him wait did you get
ghosted
did but he had a good excuse I swear
okay he was in the Mariana Trench that
day it was actually I was like sorry I
couldn't return you I was like Wow in
the Marriott friends I was like yeah I
kind of it up I think he uses
that he uses that excuse with everyone
[Laughter]
oh he's in that Trench
here you know that I like to have some
um guest questions and I think we have a
question from someone named Roger
deacons and his wife James
okay here's here's a not unexpected
question
yeah uh what do you see as the role of
the cinematographer we wish we were
there to hear the answer
amazing I think they know the answer
legendary
what's a cinematographer
the who does the what cuts the picture
together oh yeah he was nice that guy
was nice
um for me Jeff Waldron shot uh Haunted
Mansion
um and you should absolutely woo him he
is he's incredible we met on the first
season of uh my show dear white people
he helped sort of take the look that we
created from the film and and make it
for the series and um
he's a Storyteller I mean he actually
started an animation yeah I think
actually the truth is is like every
director and cinematographer
relationship is kind of different and
specific
um but for me he was uh you know he
takes something that for me is like an
idea that sort of sounds really really
great but has absolutely no
understanding of the technical
limitations uh or requirements to make
that idea come to life
um and then takes that and expands it
and expounds upon it and you know helps
figure out which lenses we need to
acquire or in some cases create to
achieve that look he sort of helps you
know at least for me uh link up
the intentions of the scenes and of the
stories and and these different beats
with actual specifics like how do we
light this and I gotta say from for for
our film for Haunted Mansion
um you know we have a lot of heavily
melanated uh cast members and
um yeah that you should also woo that
uh and you know one of the things that
we talked a lot about was you know when
you see black people in movies
especially if they're the only black
person in the movie you might notice
that you can barely see them sometimes
and they need to be lit differently and
I can't really tell you exactly how to
do that but I just know that I want to
see lakeith stanfield's whole face uh
when he's standing next to you know Owen
Wilson and um and that's actually Quite
a feat that's actually quite a technical
feat uh so uh you know that's how Jeff
Waldron helped me sort of not embarrass
myself
um
I think my DP are in are you here orange
come on Aaron you gotta stand up he
asked for tickets we give him tickets
where are you Aaron
there you go there you go there wow
amazing
orange shot the Creator where with Greg
Fraser
um
yeah the DP is like I I mean it's
sacrilegious to say this because there's
a lot of important roles on a movie
everyone's very important you're all
special
um
everybody would say like the cast is the
most important people and and they are
they are but
um for me like it's probably the most
important hire on a film yeah they're
essentially your voice like whatever you
do is going through them and you can I
don't know about you but I have like an
allergic reaction just to an image when
it doesn't feel like yes me yes and and
you need to find someone who has the
same sort of handwriting as you
and uh and so it's quite Quite a feat
and there's only a few people that I
would
um like trust handing the Sword of Omens
to
um that was a Thundercats reference for
everybody who's over 45
um and so yeah and we shot this film The
Creator very differently
I don't know how much to go into it uh
yeah but it wasn't it wasn't the normal
approach
it's a question can I ask Gareth about
your methodology because I know you want
to keep it a secret but I heard about it
and it's incredible just scream yeah or
nay
yay
well we'll talk about it later it
sounded like it was actually him the way
they shot the Creator is absolutely
incredible uh
and then for me the DP is my I mean it's
the most amazing partnership but also
I'm their worst enemy because I I
operate and I do Steadicam I do the NM
I don't wait I just go and the DP is
that like running around trying to light
this stuff I'm like shut okay reversed
it and I go I do stuff so the DPS that
work with me are
incredible because they can just follow
it's it's a flow thing and it's kind of
like it's a Vibe and you know a DP will
not stop the the rhythm of the scene
they'll just find the moment it's just
it's a you know it's you prep together
you do this but when
as we talked about before like the day
of Everything Changes you seize
opportunities the sun rises you know
clouds come do this do that yes white
people black people on frame that's
actually that it's very important that
all that stuff changes but you need to
be able to
[Music]
find you know seize that moment that
that grab that magic and real dp's real
incredible DPS will it's a
non-communicative you look at each other
you wink wink wink you understand enough
you go and you go you shoot what you you
want and it's amazing yeah it's
impossible as a filmmaker to focus on
every important detail uh when you're on
a set so for me it's like it's so great
to be able to kind of drill down to
what's essential to tell the story and
know that all those other details that
are going to really really matter
especially when I'm the edit in the edit
and cursing myself for not thinking
about them
um that's you know at least that's what
that's what that's how my dpus work for
me it's like uh it's a beautiful
relationship when it's good and like you
said you know you have to communicate to
all these hundreds of people your ideas
over and over and over again the DP is
like you know ideally someone you don't
have to talk to anymore or you do have
to talk to them but not as much you know
there is a you hope by the time you're
on set there's a kind of just like
symbiotic uh shared brain yep
if you could get the financing to make
anything you want or take on any IP uh
what would you make and why
I want to make the whiz like so bad like
oh my God
uh I want to make it so bad The Wiz of
the first movie I ever saw so by the
time I Saw The Wizard of Oz I didn't
understand why they had made a white
version of The Whiz like I truly didn't
get it
um and so like my understanding of film
like I I can't like it was a black
Centric Universe with like Quincy Jones
music it's a really weird and disturbing
movie to watch as an adult
um uh but God that's that's one I would
love to do
hey here's here's the fun thing about
movies like I don't have the rights to
the Wiz
and uh the folks that do have another
Wizard of Oz uh pretty big one uh coming
out so you know maybe once that once
Wicked is is is in and out and I'm about
you know 20 years older maybe then I
don't know we'll see
um I I I do want to do this IP I do want
to do and I have is it also The Wiz yeah
I'm really wow okay got it
I'm just kidding we gotta stir up some
controversy man this is what you know
um yeah there is there is IP that I'd
really like to do I've contacted the
people I know the people that own the IP
I'm trying to do it if I say it out loud
it won't happen so I'm going to keep
that bit quiet back what it's the Wiz
It's the weird we would give that's why
you can't do it I'm really sorry Gareth
and Justin Simeon are in a feud over who
will direct The Wiz
we can co-direct it huh we can co-direct
it all right I'll do I'll do the first
one though no I
I uh
because I know it won't happen so I'll
say it I don't care I would love because
I think I think it's I would love to do
a fortnight movie I would love to do the
photo yeah
yeah it would be because because it's
spreadable but the you the characters I
think there's so much more uh to be told
your fortnite would be amazing well it'd
be funny
yeah oh I want that no but that's the
thing it'll be like you know full of
action and everything I think I think
that I'd love to do that you know it's
not a huge risk because I know it will
never happen but you know you know what
you know what I would do actually
thinking about it is um
I don't know if you know this but when
NASA goes to space there's a very narrow
bandwidth of video signal they can send
back right yeah so when they do the
first man Mission to Mars
um someone needs to have already cut
them the footage put it together and
sort of like present a film back to the
people of Earth and so I think they're
going to put a filmmaker in in that
cruise and so um I would highly
recommend you get
um a filmmaker that knows science
fiction yeah
um is available I I
you know Tom Cruise is going to space to
do a movie right you know I I wanted to
be that director that goes with him but
my wife said there's no way you're not
allowed because I crash in helicopters
I've done like crazy stuff before you
know yeah yeah it happens so so uh so
she said nah space nah nah I'll go right
ahead
I fall a lot yeah I Stumble so yeah
anyway yeah so I don't think I can sorry
Gareth you should yeah I know well
Justin's going to be busy shooting The
Wiz I'm gonna I'm gonna be busy on Earth
okay
um
absolutely not for me but I can't wait
to see it can't wait I would totally go
I'm going to read this question uh in
this era of Ip it feels like the only
thing Studios feel safe making are
sequels spin-offs or things based on IP
people know all three of you have made
projects using well-known IP but also
made original films how do you see the
future landscape in Hollywood do you
think the studios will focus more and
more on IP is the future of Original
Stories going to be pushed more to the
Indie scene
I mean it's really simple maths to be
honest like the way it works is uh they
put films in the cinema when lots of
people go to see them they make more of
those films when people don't they make
different films and so the way this
changes if people want original
filmmaking in cinema is go support
emotional filmmaking
like
yes
go see every Fast and Furious movie and
then first
finish the Fast and Furious franchise
and then you can go see the rest yeah
but I agree no you're right Garrett I
mean ultimately
you know yeah Fast and Furious was not a
franchise 25 years ago it's like you
know you need those original uh you know
movies that that that change everything
like I yeah I've started I've done I've
picked up franchises I've started
franchises and it's it's because you
know it's really about uh it's really
about the the you know the characters
the material the themes it's about
everything but we need to you know it's
cyclical you know after all these movies
are these these amazing franchises are
done there'll be new ones uh Creator
Haunted Mansion you know like yeah these
are these are things that will become I
was like when when it first came to LA
and all that stuff after you make a
little Indie movie I was like I'm not
gonna do it I'm just gonna make my own
films I'm gonna figure out the next one
there's no way on Earth you can't talk
me into it it's not going to happen do
you want to do Godzilla I was like
of course you do sorry sorry
yeah is better the same same thing
happened I think and then after that I
was like that's it that's the end of it
not doing another no way so that was it
do you want to do Star Wars I mean
but also honestly but also
there's a the the two you just mentioned
are a really beautiful blend of the two
you know it's an original story in an
existing framework and I think both are
important because let's not forget Star
Wars began as a weird puppet kids movie
that like was opening in two theaters
that nobody
believed in and it's because of that
movie that we all live in a version of
Hollywood where we come to like San
Diego and dressed as things to talk
about Cinema because like it it always
start look at you look Mandalorian is
right in the front right here
is it yeah
come on mando
come on stand up Mando out here in these
streets hot streets but look it's like
you you can't get there without the
original
um and I think you got to have a mix of
both and I really long for uh you know
when these when when starting a
franchise is just as exciting I do yeah
one of the
come on Jeff give it up for Jeff
this is actually a serious question uh
one of the big things uh everyone is
talking about right now is AI and the
future of AI in Hollywood what's that
uh one of the reasons sag and the WJ are
on strike is AI
um how do you view Ai and its place in
Hollywood
jareth I was going to say Justin this is
very appropriate for your film The
Haunted Mansion yes because AI was as we
all know invented in the 1800s
which are where the ghosts are all from
no I mean AI is extremely important it's
extremely scary too I think that really
where the heat you're getting you're
hearing from the actors and the writers
and frankly the directors as well
um you know the DGA was we were able to
actually get AI in the language which
was a hard feat and hopefully we can
expand upon it because
it's a world in which like you kind of
feel like the artist can get squeezed
out and especially uh if you're making
work that maybe isn't paying the bills
but it's out there it just AI doesn't
work without other human people making
art that it basically kind of steals and
blends into other things and you kind of
get this feeling that like boy if the
guys at the top could just make these
things without these pesky artists that
they would
um and that feeling isn't isn't out of
nowhere okay it's uh it's something that
I think if you go through the Crucible
of Hollywood you feel you feel that uh
in a number of ways so I think it's
important both to protect the artist
whose worker are getting pulled into all
of these different AI models but also
you know I just don't think it's as fun
or as it's interesting as letting like
humans tell stories to other humans I
don't know
I mean the first thing we're all
directors up here I think we all agree
with this that the first thing we do
want to make clear is we all stand with
the writers and actors
and getting a fair deal
we're contractually obliged to promote
our movies yes we were we were told to
be here
look there also we're all like I don't
know you seem a little more extroverted
but I I would much prefer to be at home
no shade no shade to you guys I would
much rather be at home looking at
Rosario Dawson uh via YouTube I'm just
replacing a guy that couldn't be here to
get a free ticket to the coming
I'm just here
yeah uh there's another question I'm
going to read and uh I've heard a lot of
people are going after the life rights
of people so they can be used in movies
uh if someone came to you and said
between Ai and deep fake technology uh
we can get Orson Welles Marilyn Monroe
and whoever else you want in a movie and
it will look almost real would you want
to direct something like that and what
are your feelings about this technology
because this is being worked on right
now and is something that will be in the
future
hell no
personally
they made great movies while they were
alive like let's watch those
I think it's weird personally I think
it's weird it's like you can't avoid it
in some ways and and especially like as
these uh you know franchises go on and
on
um you know it's it's really cool to be
able to have the original actors sort of
image in the thing it helps make the
storytelling feel more uh cohesive so
it's not like a never kind of a thing
but solely starring you know CGI
versions of once alive humans I don't
that's not for me that's not for me I
mean what I don't know about you guys
but what I found is whenever you do a CG
character of any kind whatever it is is
it has to be based on an underlying
performance yes if you are just
animating it from scratch it gets into
uncanny valley really fast yeah and
anything good I've seen on the internet
even with AI deep fakes and stuff it's
always based on a performance underneath
of a human and I've not seen anything
yet that looks good
uh that is not not that and I found that
when we were making like this film
there's um characters in this movie that
are Ai and um and there's one played by
a great actor called Emma who we turned
into a robot and and with ilm every time
and we never really did it but if we
strayed Away by one pixel wow from what
this guy did it felt wrong wow and so
you just have to completely kind of all
you're doing really is just converting
every little idea every little
fluctuation in the eyebrow straight into
the you know CG character otherwise it's
the best thing in the world that we're
good at is looking at another person's
face and knowing if something's off if
they're lying or something's not quite
right right like we're just we've
evolved to be like perfect at it and you
can't trick people and so in who knows
it might happen like a my AI might get
there at some point but
um it's not there today yeah
you know I feel I don't know how related
this is but um I was uh posting on my
Instagram uh this footage of uh Max
fleischer's Snow White
1933 uh which has this incredible
performance of this like ghost kind of
character like singing this song and
it's Cab Calloway this is like motion
capture actually being invented
um and because of that that technology
you have this amazing performance that
comes from one of the greatest black
jazz artists of all time and continues
to inform Cinema because you really
don't get to the Disney Snow White
without Max Fleischer inventing
rotoscoping technology so that he can
transfer uh the unique performance of
cap Callaway uh forever into film uh and
we still go back to that performance
that's the performance that the genie
even Aladdin is based on
um and so there's something beautiful
about the technology but it sort of like
like you said it it requires a human
being underneath it uh you can't ever
quite get away from that and there are a
lot of those alive still and they're
they're they're really interesting and
they're Reinventing it
um so you know I think there's a role
for AI um in what we do I think it could
actually be an exciting technology if we
can figure out how to control it and
keep it you know from howling us uh you
know in our movies yeah but let's just
hope that there's a reset button if if
need be like yeah you listen no I I've
heard the Pentagon have just installed
um on the nuclear Arsenal weapon launch
system uh one of those website Pages the
way you have to recognize a traffic
light or a bicycle perfect yeah
I I always fail these I don't know yeah
it's hard the staircases the bicycles
I've never have you noticed when you
make a mistake and it still goes you're
a human yeah yeah that is concerning to
me now
I always picture some poor robot trying
to log into a website and seeing this
and going like Karen
bicycles they have the round thing are
they
no bicycles have two round circles
uh I think we have another video
question from someone named Edgar huh
hey there sdcc this is Edgar Wright
speaking it's been 10 years since I was
last at Comic-Con and I'd love a good
excuse to come back but way back in 2006
I was there with Nick Frost and we were
promoting Hot Fuzz which we had just
wrapped filming and while we were there
on our PR team was one Justin Simeon who
was on stage with you right now and
Justin really looked after me and Nick I
think he said to me in an email that one
of his tasks was to find a jazz
cigarette for me that is absolutely not
true it was for Nick Frost anyway that's
not my question my question to Justin
and also to Louis and Gareth is two Park
Western now when people say Tupac
question in the hall it's always
annoying but I'm gonna do it anyway a
two-part question number one what is the
scariest Disney movie and why
or scariest Disney scene
number two what is the scariest Kids
film of all time I would love your
answers and have a fantastic comic on
bye bye
I don't know what a jazz cigarette is
I don't know what he's talking about at
all
um scariest Disney movie Return to Oz is
a Disney movie isn't it
that that is scary as hell
um if it's not I'm gonna have to go with
Pinocchio
Pinocchio scares the crap out of me
and scary is seeing for sure uh wait
wait wait wait wait scariest Poltergeist
we were just talking about this how is
Poltergeist a PG movie
is that yeah it's it's I think it's one
of the reasons we have PG-13 George is a
PG what's that I think Jaws is a PG Jaws
is pg2 Right Poltergeist though I'm
sorry
[Laughter]
guys messes with me to this day okay
I don't know what do you guys think
Disney I mean Disney you guys Disney is
quite scary I mean if you look at like
you know
no the scariest scene the scariest scene
in a movie with Mickey Mouse
is hands down Steamboat Willie
I know everything I'm gonna say is um
the transformation scene in American
Werewolf in London yeah do you remember
that yeah yeah and as his as his whole
face is distorting and he's screaming in
pain he just looks on his mantelpiece
and there's Mickey Mouse just staring
back at him
and it's like this I that I saw that
when I was six years old and I never
slept in my own bed for the next five
years
my parents ended up getting divorced
because I ruined their sex life I think
wow that's the reason I mean sorry their
love their love life sorry okay
uh Edgar wanted to also know what's the
scariest Kids film of all time
can I you know
I the default answer for me would be the
Dark Crystal but yeah there's a scarier
Jim Henson thing that used to I couldn't
watch it I had to leave the room was
um on The Muppets um Pigs in Space yeah
like it was it was science fiction so my
my mom would think I would like this
picture like oh Gareth Gareth it's Pigs
in Space you know and turn it up and and
it freaked me out the fact these were
pigs everyone was a pig and no one was
acknowledging it it was like Star Trek
but with pig faces and I would run out
the room screaming and they'd be like no
no it's it's spaceships you like this
and they're like they're pigs they're
pigs why can no one see this
oh Crystal he's not scary that Crystal
is
it's not scary though Crystal it's like
yeah whatever I made it a little scarier
but you know the original one was it was
it was sweet you know I was like yeah a
nice one yeah but your movie is going to
be quite scary no it's got some chills
and some Thrills you know I love
traumatizing children I don't I don't
mean that
I mean inspiring them to be brave
I was inspired to be brave uh at like
five years old watching Nightmare on Elm
Street so I I don't know I love that
stuff
um I I don't know I think Poltergeist is
still a pretty scary kids film uh have
you guys seen The Little Prince though
like the original Little Prince with Bob
Fosse
wow okay I'm disappointed first of all
in all of you wrong crowd Jeff can you
queue up Little Prince
that movie is haunting
uh I'm curious if you could all talk
about working with the marketing
department because one of the things
everyone in this room watches trailers
and um the and I think a lot of us feel
that the the marketing gives a lot away
so can you sort of talk about how you
work what is it like working with
marketing and figuring out what shots
are going to go in there and what shots
you're like absolutely not we are not
giving this away it really means too
much to me
considering Disney paid for us to be
here uh considering it's their literal
marketing department as well
um I think they're the greatest in the
whole industry it was amazing
it was amazing it was collaborative
um
every time I said hey let's not do that
they were like cool and then they did it
it was awesome
it's it's knowing when you're wrong
isn't it yeah it's like you know I I was
wrong I'm really glad that you didn't
know
honestly I think
I think it's like movies don't have a
lot of time right like you the opening
weekend is so important that like in
those weeks leading up to it uh it's
like throw the kitchen sink in there
because if people don't come out that
opening weekend like the whole thing's
done you you used to be able to kind of
craft a story about the story and sort
of have that roll out and trickle
through Society ain't nobody got time
for all that
Barbie at Oppenheimer in theaters okay
we have to like get these kids in the
theaters so I apologize if you don't
want Haunted Mansion spoiled for you
just don't look at anything with your
eyes
anywhere does that include the movie no
watch the movie God please Lord Jesus
watch the movie
um but when you leave this room like
don't look at anything
visually speaking
all right you want to see a movie stop
looking at Marcus agreed yes I've
decided I want to see Oppenheimer yes
I'm gonna get dragged to Bobby and so I
know I'm seeing it so I haven't watched
a single thing yes because I want to
just see it all fresh for the first time
um when you opt in just stop yeah and
I've watched trailers for things I'm
unsure about and the problem is when you
don't have IP franchise it's brand new
stuff you have to kind of um like
educate the audience or whatever they
say about what your film is about and so
I'm like the worst person in the world
when they show you a trailer or a poster
or whatever they thinking what do you
think Gareth you know I mean like it's
like your little it's been a little kid
that you've raised for like the last few
years and you they like you're thinking
oh no you it doesn't like his hair
parted that way and he never no he's you
know he doesn't like that kind of coat
and he shouldn't be and they're like
Gareth it's like we'll take care of this
you know we're just taking a picture
yeah but that said
I you know I I knew your movie was
coming out I didn't know your movie was
coming out and I was checking my I was
going around to see um uh fast text fast
10 prints uh in IMAX and I saw your
trailer
and it was so incredible I mean right
Holly is like Korea is an amazing
trailer it is mind-blowing and when you
know how he's got how you shot it this
is it
I that that first of all you ruined my
experience for my movie thank you but I
was like so excited and it's it's hard
again it goes back to that first this
first question of like you know how do
we create new franchise and everything
you know there's so many people in the
world consuming entertainment such in a
different way now that we have to find a
way to to grab them especially when it's
something as original as the Creator yes
come on original can I just say I'm all
we can see we can't see you we can just
see these screens of what what's being
filmed or videoed and I'm slowly falling
in love with Louis he's so handsome
I agree
wasn't okay once you release a movie and
you're like
and actually you know lose weight
Brothers No No Yeah we could just wait
and get it to hand
uh technology is always changing behind
the scenes and I'm curious if you have
seen anything whether it be
um with CGI with cameras whatever it may
be that you're excited to use in the
future or if you've seen anything behind
the scenes that is like on the cusp of
coming out finally we can talk about
oh
um well obviously there is lots of
things and I guess the thing you're
talking about is so um
I don't know technology there's always
been this promise with technology with
Moore's Law and all this sort of stuff
that that the difference for a long time
the difference between shooting on film
you know making a very expensive film
and what you might call the consumer or
prosumer like the stuff you can buy in
the stores is getting narrower and
narrower and that gap's getting you know
indistinguishable to some extent we shot
the Creator on a new camera it's a Sony
camera it's called it fx3
um pretty much the whole movie shot on
this
um it's a
camera you can buy Best Buy yeah it
looks like film
um it's full frame full IMAX resolution
um and has filmic like really
photographic quality to it it can shoot
in Moonlight I don't know if you
remember this with cameras but you um
you basically remember film stocks and
you would get like a 100 ASA or ISO and
it would go up to 800 if it was dark you
might need a 800 well this does 12 800.
wow so you could you can shoot in
Moonlight and and as a result it meant
that we didn't need big massive lights
so we had these like LED lights that are
just really lightweight they're kind of
featherweight and so you know like how
people hold booms on a set we had um our
gaffer kind of best boy uh Nancy was
kind of holding a LED and so we would
light it by as we could be really
organic if suddenly the shot looked like
the actors had this freedom and suddenly
the shot looked better over here Nancy
would suddenly move around with the
light and Oren would be talking to Nancy
through a little microphone and we were
just really fluid organic we'd shoot for
like 25 minutes at a time and it was
like a very liberating experience and it
it looks like a much bigger film than it
cost because of that reason
um because everything he sees on screen
hopefully I mean this is incredible what
you are in Greg Fraser you've you guys
have changed Cinema forever what's up
what's about to happen What you're going
to see at the end of our thing is going
to change Cinema forever meaning that
the three of us here it doesn't you guys
can become filmmakers tomorrow that
means that it's amazing so that it
really is tomorrow not tomorrow not
today not today I'm watching the panel
August yeah yeah a second today we need
you all to open your phones to
fandango.com
today and buy these tickets
I think we have another video question
this is from someone named Joseph who is
currently making an F1 movie with Brad
Pitt
sorry this is late Frosty but uh one of
the things I love about my job
how different it is in every phase from
prep to shooting to post totally
different job so my question for the
panel is
what's your favorite part
of directing
and why
it's walking with my phone asking
questions wearing shades with Shades
yeah shades and
ferrariants
are cool yeah
the hairline you know it's everything I
have to pause I I actually asked Joe
instead of doing like you know in his
office I'm like you're filming an F1
movie do me a favor and show something
from F1 behind you I've been waiting for
Brad Pitt to turn up at the end I was
like that whole strike thing you know
all right oh yeah that'd be awkward
yeah
what was the question what's your
favorite aspect of directing making film
like in the whole process yeah and and
promotion here today at Comic-Con
my favorite part is before like you're
actually making it like before anyone
gets there and you can dream and no one
has told you no yet and you haven't had
to convince anybody yet that your idea
is okay
um when it's like one or two or three of
you or even just by yourself and you
just get to dream I mean that's how I
sort of got into the idea that I wanted
to be a filmmaker is uh you know laying
going to sleep and putting on a movie
soundtrack and trying to imagine like
how I would tell a story or how I would
like put a scene together
um so the part before your dreams are
crushed I think is my favorite part I
feel like I need to hug you
thank you thank you I have a lot of
therapy
in a similar way my favorite bit is the
very beginning when you like fantasize
about how amazing and world-changing
this movie is going to be and the very
end when you get to come here and hit
play and people get to see it and
everything in the middle is a nightmare
nightmare and it's like the end is good
for you too I'm just saying that because
they've come out and they pay a lot of
money okay and we have to play a clip
yeah we've got to be positive no it's
really fun finishing a movie it's like
the ultimate sandwich
like this nice bread either side yeah
and then just a lot of I feel like
mine's an open face sandwich
hahaha yeah yours is like a Pizza
yeah
it's a sheets uh it's a sheets uh that's
okay for under 18 right yeah as much as
we get it
do you guys I'm in I feel like I I have
a process not a process really but I I
have a period of mourning when a film is
over because you have to sort of let go
of the movie that you imagine you'd make
at the beginning there's no and I'm not
even being funny there's just like
there's kind of I don't know that
there's any way around it even when
something really hits and it's great and
it works in ways you couldn't imagine
um I find that like right at the end
there's like this like kind of a
downbeat of like oh that's where we
landed I don't know how about you guys
also the movie's great by the way oh my
God what am I doing
[Laughter]
but it's just different it's just
different from what you first you know
what first got you excited no one else
is going to jump on that train I am so
sorry Disney do you want me to leave out
that way or
as you say like it's funny to imagine
it's great to shoot in post you pull
your hair out and at the same time you
discover your movie for the first time
because you see it Through The Eyes of
an audience and uh no it's it's it's we
have very interesting lives and also you
know what I like about being a director
is like I change lives every couple of
years I am a magician for two years I'm
a puppeteer for two years I was hoping
to go to space but I can't because
there's still time I hope I can one day
anyway but yeah so that's what's great
about the Earth failing uh what is a
detail or decision that you had to fight
for in one of your films that you are
the most proud of
I just want to say I really love
releasing a movie into theaters
no no I didn't get to mention that um
before I love finishing it and I'm sorry
no but we I mean honestly we
collectively the three of us are so
lucky all of us oh oh you know almost 7
000 people kind of uh here in this room
are are lucky to have theaters still
open after yeah yeah it's real
all right
and to have movie to be able to see our
movies with an audience that's something
that
you know almost disappeared so yeah
let's count Our Stars thank you thank
you movie theaters thank you yes thank
you Nicole Kidman
her break really does feel good in a
place like this
I'm real I mean that
does anyone uh take a swing at the
question or we're just gonna oh no no no
detail right which detail we fought for
what's it what's a detail or decision
that you had to fight for that you're
really like proud of because you made it
work and it worked out
I'm I'm
very happy I cast Mark Ruffalo as Hulk
in my Hulk but then it wasn't cast but
it's my Hulk but then ended up being
Hulk you know so so that's a mind blow
that I was going to say something else
um that's a mind screw that's amazing
I don't know I don't know
um I would say there on this movie
because you know
um probably and it didn't have to fight
for it that was the strange thing is
just being allowed to shoot we you make
a very low budget movie right and and
there's massive advantages to making it
independent Just You and Your Friends
type movie and then there's massive
advantages and disadvantages to making a
big Blockbuster and for me the simplest
way to explain it is you just swap each
one round whatever's easy on a low
budget film is hard on a big budget and
whatever's hard and easy on the other
one is the other way around and so the
the Holy Grail is like how to marry
those two together and so on this movie
this was us trying even harder like come
on let's try and get this right
um we shot like a quite classically like
a conventional film but then at the end
for a month they let me go off with just
this the main cast there's about five or
six of us and we went to five different
countries we went to Nepal we went to
the top of the Himalaya layers we went
to Indonesia Tokyo we went to Cambodia
and just shot like a gorilla like low
budget film in a way and had all this
freedom and then married that with all
the like bigger bigger scale stuff in
the movie with ilm and everything in it
and hopefully when you watch it you
can't quite say oh that was that moment
that was that moment and I feel like
there's like want to push that further
every time but
um that was something that I thought
they were going to fight the entire time
and they were always like I was waiting
at the last minute for them to say and
you can't go on that trip yeah and they
didn't so that was good I had to I had
to pay for the whole thing myself but
you know it came out my wage but well
you had the camera from Best Buy so it's
fine right
um with Haunted Mansion there I mean the
job partly was details it was like I was
obsessed with the ride and part of why
that ride is so enduring is because it
is meticulously crafted the details are
so specific and they are everywhere so
um there were so many details and it
wasn't a fight I mean I think Disney
more than anyone understood the power of
those details but I'll sum it up in
saying that like I was really passionate
about starting with practical in-camera
effects I felt like that's part of the
magic of that ride
um it is Pepper's ghost and literal
smoke and mirrors and uh you know we we
went out there and I was like guys I
really I don't wanna I wanna build the
Mansion I know that's a big ass but I
want to build these interiors and I want
to actually drag Tiffany haddish in the
chair you know through this thing I
don't I don't want everything to sort of
be just play pretend and make believe
and that was really exciting that they
let me do that
um and and the other detail I got to say
that I was pretty adamant about was that
I really wanted a black lead for my
movie This Is The Haunted Mansion
um is situated in New Orleans which is
an 85 black town and I love the ride I
love Disneyland but I didn't I didn't
see any black people uh like on the
paintings on the walls in this uh New
Orleans mansion and I felt pretty
strongly that um we had to we had to do
right by New Orleans uh in that movie so
I don't know how big a fight they were
but those were two things that were
really important to me coming into that
film
really
I was going to say uh we have a question
from Chad and I think it's aimed at one
of you uh-oh
to Louie who wins the fight Dom Toretto
nobe or Frank Martin
and how quickly does John Wick beat the
winner
I yes I know it was all about John Wick
yes John Wick Chad it's all about I knew
he would finish with it with John Wick
thing I mean that guy that guy
but how quickly would John Wick beat
them yes
it's just enough John Wick would throw
an ax in Dom Toretto kick Frank Martin
in somewhere in his body where it hurts
and yeah it's John Wick yeah yeah
absolutely yeah
uh what would you say is an important
lesson that each of you have learned
about this business that seems
invaluable to you now but that you might
not have been able to receive or been
open to hearing early on in your career
patience
patience endurance I remember in film
School they'd be like 90 of you will
never make it
and if you do it'll take 20 years and I
used to hate that and it was so true
it was so true it takes so long to make
a movie It Takes years and God forbid
you write it uh also so I think um
sticking with it and and kind of even
though literally the job is to be goal
oriented to put that side of your brain
kind of on pause for the extreme amount
of time it takes to to actually bring a
movie to life
um I guess the thing you learned when
you set out you kind of go I want to
make these amazing films want everyone
to love them and it's going to be
amazing and then suddenly you put them
out into the world and some people hate
them and they'll let you know and and
it's a shock to start with and um and I
think one of the best bits of advice I
got from my on my first film is when we
were talking about this sort of thing
that the producers said
Gareth you can't make a five-star movie
like you just can't you can you you've
got two choices you either make
a five and a one star movie like some
people will love it some people will
hate it or you make a three-star movie
and everyone thinks it's okay
and he was like that's your choice
and um I've just ended up making two
star movies so I'm not sure how that
fits in so that just realizes it falls
apart once I go forward geez that's
really good advice though uh
I think it's my rule my my one thing I
realized but that's your place to direct
the mirror place in life too which is
like never
be the first one to speak like listen
listen to everyone listen to your
producers to your studio to your cast
your crew the best ideas come from your
Pas listen to everything but never be
the first one to speak although you have
all the power as a director on set be
just be a sponge learn get everything
and then it will help you in everything
it'll help you you know creatively and
you also it will help you uh you know
with your contract you know never make
the first offer you know let them come
up then you'll say no I want more
I think we actually have another
question from Chad oh my God
hi guys so someone puts a big Briefcase
full of money down on a table in front
of you they give you complete control
what movie from your childhood are you
gonna remake
I think I think we have one of their
answers already
the ways yeah
I really want to make the Wiz can y'all
help me with that
that Emerald City sequence y'all ain't
ready y'all are not ready for what I
have planned
do you have to give the big Briefcase
full of money back at the end right does
it does it have to make a profit does
some of that might cover my like living
costs also do you have something I feel
like I've been given a big Briefcase
full of money and I've gotten to do like
my favorite IP same thing wow
um same thing but for you guys now guys
guys the real question is Chad which
movie from your child doing are you
going to remake with that big briefcase
of money they just put in front of your
lab
that's the question and you choose as
him very soon
wow that was cryptic yeah
why do we know something what do you
know which one is it I know things see
what what what is not being said here is
that Louie and Chad are good friends so
he clearly does know something that we
do not I what
is it the Wiz it's the Wiz The Whiz by
Chad healthy will be amazing
by the way when I said I'd already been
getting body count when I said I'd
already been given a big Briefcase full
of money to make my favorite IP from
when I was a kid I meant The Wiz
it was in a meeting about a month I'm
sorry no it's okay I love White remix of
The Wiz
oh he's on down the road
[Laughter]
can't wait
uh there's an individual question for
Louie
um I'd like to jump back in time uh you
directed The Incredible Hulk back in
2000 what uh what people will not
remember is the movie came out I believe
like a month after Iron Man before
Marvel Studios was Marvel Studios and um
what do you actually remember about
making that movie and at the time did
you have any idea or could you feel what
was about to happen with this no well so
think it's it's quite quick question
it's funny that was my first comic con
it was like in 2016 six seven something
it was just not here in room 25 by the
bathroom there's like seven you know
there's like 20 people in the room it
was Edgar it was John Favreau myself and
then Edgar Wright who was supposed to do
an Ant-Man sitting down with avirad
Kevin feige was like
you know the the exact two it was not
you know it was just like almost like an
assistant it was it was incredible we're
in like we had we were like in the
offices of ex-offices of Playboy
magazine I had to use uh funny you know
sort of like pen pencils from John
Favreau uh you know I couldn't buy new
pencils I had to buy like shooter
pencils from trump favro it was
incredible it was like you know the
movies were financed by the firemen you
know fund or something it was crazy it
was crazy it was we we were making small
movies that were so passionate about it
was so different no one was figure out
and then you know and then one day we
all had the idea the idea I was like you
know maybe you know what if what if I
bring uh Tony Stark at the end of my
movie what if I you know what happened
we ended up cutting that scene but I put
the the you know Hall you know British
Banner goes in the Arctic in the
beginning tries to uh takes himself
taking himself out strips his clothes
puts a gun in his mouth I don't know why
they had us cut this scene out of this
movie but it was really good a great
opener and then hulks out and then
breaks the the uh the ice cap and then a
big uh block of ice comes to camera and
that was the uh that's how you released
the shield you know Captain America's
shield so all these ideas about creating
a joint Universe which was impossible
then we had and we're like yeah we'll
just make these two movies and then you
know we're lucky to do this but it
wasn't it was great and frankly it's
thanks to Comic-Con like I saw it was my
first time I saw you guys I saw the
passion you know we all realized that we
had something we had to give you guys
the best we could and then you know it
worked you know and then you know 30
whatever five seven movies later Marvel
is incredible so
I'm actually going to do a part two with
you uh because you just directed fast X
and and you joined the project when it
was already going you essentially joined
like a train moving at 200 miles an hour
were you apprehensive about getting on
something that was you know you you were
I don't know how much control you were
going to be able to have on the train
because it was already on the tracks
yeah so talk a little bit about your
decision you know what I mean yeah so so
Justin Lin uh not Simeon was uh the
director left uh three days in and
I was cold and I had to jump on board
but the you know the good thing is that
yes this movie the great thing about
Hollywood movies when you when that
happens is that Hollywood movies really
never have the third act figured out so
it's right that you always go in with
you have a release date but you don't
have a full script so it was kind of
interesting they didn't really have a
third act so I came in and worked on
that but then as we thought that was was
written you know he had implications on
the second and then obviously First Act
so it's sort of like was able to it's
still very much Justin's idea but but
but I was able to change it like for
example the Jason Momoa character was
completely you know what you know how
how he is in this thing was completely
you know Json and my invention it was
not written this way and then we changed
some stuff everything so it was very it
was a a true exercise in directing I
don't know if you guys would have
accepted a job like this it's funny I
was you know it happened to me twice in
my career my first movie when I was 26
uh transporter I was the second ad and
the director never showed up and they
were like I was second ID and they
showed it to the you know they said no
first first lady you're going to direct
I was like I'm not directing this piece
of I'm the first lady I'm a French
first lady I'm a genius I'm you know
yeah and then and then you know like in
the movies everybody turned to me and I
was like I guess I'll try you know and
then that's what triggered I started my
career so it happened twice in my yeah
and you sort of like step up to the
plate and you do
but also and also you know I love those
movies that's so fun it's so you know
exciting and I love I love everyone
involved so it's it was really a lovely
experience for me so so nothing bad to
say and look I've got a tan I'm healthy
didn't break me
we were broken before we became
directors
[Laughter]
Justin I want to know I don't think
everyone realizes you used to work at
Disneyland and so what does it still do
actually I never left that job no I did
what does it actually like though going
from someone who worked in the Parks
loves something so much and now you
directed this huge budget Haunted
Mansion movie I have no idea
um I it's really surreal I'm still kind
of wrapping my head around it I think
like because I never really believe that
I have the job or once I get the job
that the movie will ever come out it's
kind of just hitting me now you know
um just kind of like uh all of those
details and all those I used to ride the
Haunted Mansion uh while I was at film
you know I was I was I was working at
Disneyland to basically helped pay my
way through film school and uh I would
ride the Mansion ride I would ride
Pirates and I would honestly think like
how do I do this in a movie like how do
I sort of use production design and
sound and light and Magic to you know
kind of do that Hitchcock thing where
you like play the audience like you know
an orchestra because I would get chills
at exactly the same spots and I would
like gasp at all the same spots and
laugh and I'd see these things over and
over again they would still work
um so to be able to kind of bring all
that to bear as a filmmaker it's been
really amazing
um but I also like you know uh I
dissociate a lot that's why I think I'm
good at directing
um so I don't know maybe in a couple
weeks uh when the movie's out I'll be
able to fully answer that question but
it's been amazing well one of the things
I think I've seen Haunted Mansion and
you did such a great job and one of the
reasons it's so great is because there's
scares for kids there's so many laughs
for adults but there's also a thousand
nods to the ride yeah and so I'm just
curious what was it like in the editing
room trying to make sure that was all
serviced and also you're dealing with IP
that may means a lot to the studio so
making sure all these things are
satisfied while still making your movie
well a lot of it comes down to the story
which you know written by an amazing
screenwriter Katie dippled give it up
for Katie
um
she told a very clear story about moving
through difficult feelings and you know
giving to people things that you didn't
get yourself it was very clear what the
story was and you know my philosophy in
in The Killing Your Darlings phase of
making a movie is does it serve the
story or not and um you know we we had a
huge process of just uncovering every
possible Easter egg and thing about the
ride
um we had so much material to work with
uh so many details but at the end of the
day if it doesn't help move this
particular story forward it it it isn't
it's time to shine you know but on the
other hand like I I grew up sort of um
you know anticipate you know I was on
any cool news like refreshing to see
like the first clips of like what is
Wolverine going to look like in the
first X-Men movie and I remember seeing
that black patent leather and being like
that's
not the Wolverine I remember and
obviously like we have that's a lot
that's a whole panel in and of itself
um I actually really like that movie but
there's something so there's such it's
such a bummer when a thing you love
finally gets adapted and the people who
adapted it don't really care that much
about the little details and uh and so I
wanted to do right by the fans first of
all and I'd be I I was already obsessed
with the ride but
getting to work on the movie like
walking through that ride with the
lights on getting the history of it
understanding the the back and forth
conversations between Walt Disney and
the imagineers to make sure it is the
right amount of scary and the right
amount of funny and the right amount of
heart and all that I was really inspired
by that and I thought that they had made
a lot of really really good decisions
and so
um I was kind of obsessed with using as
much of them as I could and just
adapting them properly to this much
bigger cinematic scale
I believed we have an exclusive clip
from the movie oh wow uh would how would
you like to set it up I don't know what
it is
you're welcome here it goes
[Applause]
that was a real alligator guys
practical effects
well I have to ask you what was it how
much did you debate what that scene was
going to be because that's one of the
iconic moments of the ride well it
wasn't it wasn't there there was this
big set piece that required you know the
characters to sort of struggle to get
out of the house and uh there was like a
mention of the of the stretching room
but my feeling was like that's where the
sequence has to take place and we we
have to figure out how to make
um the fact that the room stretches kind
of like essential to the narrative and
essential to how the characters are
escaping uh and that was just a lot a
lot of fun to to to do and to conceive
you know it was like the first time I
really got to come up with some really
Bonkers off the walls stuff and
people were like okay you know that was
the
um stuff
freaking stuff y'all already been y'all
been saying all kinds
um no that was a blast that was a blast
to make and I felt like it was essential
to put a set piece out of the stretching
room you know pretty Central to the
movie
uh Gareth I have some questions for you
um well I heard when you were making
Rogue one you were always trying to have
a certain director come to set can you
sort of talk about this oh
um yeah yeah yeah uh so oh God
you get you get lots of weird things
happen to you when you make films that
are really um you can't believe is
really true one of them I got invited to
New Zealand to hang out for two weeks on
the set of The Hobbit with Peter Jackson
and and learn some very very valuable
stuff for advice for directing that I've
kept with me one of them was never
basically when you say cut on a movie
um as you well know everybody comes in
and starts doing stuff and you look at
your watch and by five ten minutes go by
and then you go for another take and you
waste about 50 of your day doing this
and Peter was like
basically if you never say cut no one
can come in and so do what's called a
rolling take and so I do that too and so
you shoot for like 25 minutes and never
say cut it's a very handy tip but anyway
so this all happened and then I was like
I've got to somewhere repay this favor I
don't know how to do it I don't know
I've got nothing I can offer Peter
Jackson what can I do and then start
making this Star Wars film and I was
like oh pee making Star Wars if you ever
want to visit you know if you want to
come to the set and like
my editor Jabez Olsen is Peter Jackson's
editor so we had that in common I just
couldn't get Peter to reply you know I
mean he's very busy he's doing stuff and
I was like look we're shooting this
other thing next I couldn't get him to
reply and then it was the last it was
the very end of filming it was the last
thing we ever did and it was this scene
in the corridor with Darth Vader and it
was like Pete it was like Pete we're
about to film Darth Vader and then any
in the next 30 minutes and he was like
I'll be there in 15 minutes
and we were setting up the shots and it
was literally it couldn't have been time
more perfectly it was like the bit where
the lights go down and he was going to
light up and the you know lightsaber
lights up and he's illuminated in the
background and stuff and we had all the
lights down and as the lights came down
late Peter Jackson kind of walks in it's
like all right Gareth Frank
he doesn't have a cockney accent
I can't do a kiwi accent and he was like
all right you know uh so what are you
doing what are you doing and it was one
of those Great Moments where you get to
go
just watch
and it was like action
that's amazing I know it's kind of more
excited because I didn't know what that
moment was going to be for that film at
that point I was more excited like it's
Peter Jackson like it's Peter Jackson
like that was like it's Darth Vader and
I'm like no no it's Peter Jackson
wow that's awesome amazing uh so I want
to actually ask you about Creator uh in
this era of Ip where how actually did
you get this made
um to be honest uh it's very simple uh
new Regency
deserve I'm gonna swear a medal
for having the balls to make an original
big scale epic sci-fi movie
I just I was I was about to in theory
was about to do another film
and it wasn't like which one
[Laughter]
[Music]
maybe you know something from my
childhood
yeah
um so there was another film I was
supposed to maybe going to be doing and
I've been working on this idea for the
Creator like oh for a couple of years
and I'd written a script had all this
concept art all my friends who were
concept artists I got them to kind of
work on it and it was I loved it and I
was like I really want to see this movie
and every the momentum was pushing me
towards the film and it there was
something about it where I was like if I
don't do this now I'm never going to do
it and so I uh Michael Schaefer who's a
new agency I texted him or something and
I was like look
um I've got this idea I really want to
picture to you but I'm not telling
anybody my agents didn't know nobody
knew I kept a complete secret and I just
went into the office and it was yarif
and Michael who run the Regency and I
was like look
um I had nothing to lose I was like here
you go I explained the story I showed
them all this artwork I talked through
the whole thing and then they took the
script and they and they just called me
later and went we're really excited we
want to do it and that was it it was
like that one of those simple stories
really and to be honest
I'm not understating this if if you go
and look at how many original like big
swing massive movies are happening this
year it's really hard to find them and
this is getting more and more the case
and it worries me as someone who grew up
with films where every movie like every
year like the top 10 movies would all be
original movies and so
um I can't take any credit for it
it all it's all on them they they found
a big Briefcase full of cash and let us
go do this crazy thing so
so
um oh I
uh so I know that we're about to show a
really effing cool sequence from your
movie how would you like to set it up oh
God you don't want me talking you just
want to hit play but I'll say real fast
it's about AI
half the world want AI band the other
half embrace it except it as equals
there's a war going on between the west
and Asia
um there's this new development the
Breakthrough is this
weapon Advanced AI whatever you want to
call it it's in the form of a child and
essentially
um the clip you're gonna see is John
David's character trying to escape this
AI village with the child whilst the
Americans come and that's probably all
you need to know wait hold on I want to
go in there and the other thing the
other thing to say is at the end there's
a little sizzle
because I really need to pee
so I'm going to go down there and pee as
well but but what you also need to know
is that
they're all going to pee they are not
watching the movie
we drank loads of water
you're also going to there's a little
Sizzle at the end a little short Sizzle
and it's set to the music of Hans Zimmer
um and Steve mazzaro and so you're gonna
hear a new hanzima track for the first
time ever
from this new movie yeah by the way you
guys I know you want to go with me yeah
this this you by the way I don't in the
history of me attending Comic-Con I've
never seen panelists all leave to use
the bathroom
they're all like I'm out uh this clip is
part of my language awesome here
we go
[Applause]
hi
where are they
I mean this is going to change
everything right
this is that looks amazing it's amazing
where did he go oh yeah dude that looks
amazing you are you were peeing in there
with me you only saw the last 10 seconds
but only for the first part
I was speaking myself in the audience
wow no it's it's incredible Gareth that
looks amazing guys Gareth get your
flowers Gareth come on Garrett Garrett
come on I mean come on speech speech
speech shot on an iPhone no man it's
incredible
shot on an iPhone now
I mean like let's genuinely hats off to
the studio that made it honestly it's
like you guys we could
it just being allowed to do something
the way you want to do it yeah it's what
it's about it is right there so Michael
Schaefer that guy he he did the same
thing to me a long time ago like my
career was like and then and then he
gave me this script called now you see
me and no one wanted to do it and he
just allowed me to do it the way and it
was great I mean so Michael Michael
Schaefer everyone your Regency
come on Michael
you're German man
where are you where's Michael where's
Natalie he's by the bathroom where are
you they're hiding that bathroom was
hopping
one of the things dude in a cave in
there was wow sorry well when you were
writing this you obviously started
writing this years ago it it the timing
of this with AI and its release and what
being the fact that it's something that
everybody is talking about right now and
acknowledging the timing is very good
but what was it about how long ago did
you start writing the script and were
you thinking you know what I mean the AI
aspect it's just it's a great time to
have it coming out you mean it's great
that robots are going to wipe out
humanity and we're really lucky yes
because of that little fact yeah
um I I would love to take credit for it
I honestly I don't know what to call it
like a fluke or what like it's a I don't
know if it's a good thing or a bad thing
um to be honest when we started doing
this the the AI was was the idea was the
AI represented other people that are
different to us that look different and
we see them as the enemy and they see us
as the enemy and that's how it started
but the second you actually have ai in
your story
all kinds of fascinating questions just
kind of bubble up really fast like are
they alive is it real how would you know
does it matter like what happens if you
want to turn them off what if they don't
want to be turned off all these sort of
really interesting ideas and even like
with the image stuff we have there's
posters and billboards in the movie that
are like donate your donate your
likeness to AI you basically get scanned
and then they can print an AI version of
you like for money they will pay you to
do that and it's to play this and and it
seemed like such science fiction you
know like I thought I was not going to
live like when you're picking the date
when you write a script and at some
point someone mentions the year I'm like
I don't want to be like Kubrick and get
it wrong you know and so like what day
what day uh and I ended up going with
2070 and I'm like now it feels like
actually gone with 2024. yeah it's like
yeah you know it's it's I don't know how
to feel about it in terms of
the AI of it all because uh it's that
that Genie's not going back in the
bottle like that's going to change
everything and anything we say about it
and try to predict about it right now
we're gonna look like fools in about
five or so years it's so hard to know
where it's going but it's like
incredibly powerful and it's frightening
even the people that are working on it
you know yeah I just think about what
what your phone looked like 10 years ago
and what your phone can do now and with
AI whatever it can't do in 10 years it's
it's very scary
yes
yeah
um so I'm just going to say thanks for
coming everybody be terrified
yeah thank you so much have a great
Comic Con I just want AI to solve like
climate change and cancer yes like does
it just have to write screenplays and
take residuals away from actors gonna do
something else in all honesty though
here's the good side of it right there's
a bad side of it and there's a
potentially good side of it the good
side of it like there
it could democratize filmmaking you know
I mean like there are tools that you
already see happening right now
you know you can type stuff in you can
and it will generate the footage I don't
know what this is going to cause for the
industry and everybody but it's um it's
a bit like it maybe might be like when
they invented the electric guitar and
then suddenly there was this creative
explosion like we call rock and roll
that we've never seen since and maybe
filmmaking is about to have that we
don't know but this is like probably
bigger than CGI and dinosaurs like this
is gonna really revolutionize or
dramatically destroy everything
anyway final Comic Con
never Comic-Con so uh we actually have
to enter two years Max
so just to let everybody know if you
don't actually know oh we have these
posters that everyone here is gonna get
can we put that's the Haunted Mansion
poster
that's the Creator and these are limited
to Comic-Con can we put the Honda
yes so um I believe and because we of
course didn't rehearse this or practice
I believe as you leave the room or if
they're coming around there's going to
be these tickets and then if I remember
correctly upstairs there's a Redemption
room where you bring the ticket and you
pick up the uh posters I'm not a hundred
percent on this and I probably should
have found out but you will be able to
get these posters and on that note
ladies and Gentlemen please say uh thank
you to our panelists
[Music]
thank you very much and guys
Frost Steve Frosty one trust me
come on
thank you uh seriously thank you guys
for coming out today and have a
fantastic Comic-Con thank you everyone
see ya thank you